on the 17th of April a battery of
155-millimeter howitzer x' prepares to
fire a mission in support of 25th
Infantry Division troops engaged in
operation Longfellow the target is an
area being prepared as a landing zone in
contem province final instructions come
from the FDC as the big tube artillery
is prepared for firing the battery is
firing from positions near Duk toe 480
kilometers north northeast of Saigon
elevation adjustments are completed and
the firing commences now the entire
battery is in action even as this
barrage fire is covering the landing
zone area tropic lightning troops are
mounting their assault helicopters for a
successful move to the forward landing
zone
during the period 29 April through one
may additional units of the 25th
Infantry Division were filmed as they
arrived at the Seaport of buntao
Republic of Vietnam in a shuttle service
LC TS ferry the men from their troop
ships to the beach on shore the division
band greets the landing troops the
beachhead is located some 64 kilometers
southeast of the capital city of Saigon
as the Tropic lightning troops reach the
beach phase one of operation moonlight
is completed phase two of the massive
deployment is to move the Hawaiian based
outfit inland to their new base of
operations at Kushi for the trip to the
divisions headquarters in Vietnam 96
kilometers to the northwest the arriving
elements are taken to nearby vung tau
airstrip they will be flown from here to
Khushi as the more than 4,000 new troops
complete the final phase of operation
moonlight
camp alpha situated at tonsure Newt on
the outskirts of Saigon is the trans
shipping center for both incoming and
outgoing troops of the 173rd Airborne
Brigade in South Vietnam on this day
early in May a group of replacements
fresh from stateside load aboard buses
for the 28 kilometers rive to Benoit
arriving at the 173rd base camp at
Benoit the new men are completely
processed by the personnel of the
administration company briefing and unit
assignments are followed by stops at
records section and Finance after
processing the replacement soldiers
board waiting trucks and are taken to
their respective units for them the war
against the Vietcong is about to begin
at the same time other men are being
rotated back to CONUS no troops are held
overnight at the processing center and
all are soon on their way for the
returnees camp alpha is the gateway to
home here there transportation back to
the States is arranged for these
veterans of the Vietnam campaign a
long-awaited moment has arrived
camp McDermott headquarters for field
force one Vietnam is located at not rung
40 kilometers north of Cam Ranh Bay the
old Grand Hotel now serves as the
headquarters building for the command
the camp opened on 13 February is shown
here in film shot on the 3rd of May
during the 10 weeks the camp has been in
existence it has been greatly expanded
to handle thousands of troops a
construction program is going forward to
convert from tents to frame buildings
and concrete foundations have already
been poured for many of the structures
one of the units assigned to Camp
McDermott is an MP company the military
police not only provides security for
the headquarters here but they perform
many of the same type of duties as they
would in the United States as the camp
has grown the MPS find their activity is
increasing speeders along the highway
between the camp and the town of Natron
are given tickets just as anywhere else
for many years Natron has been a popular
coastal resort city and is densely
populated speeding is out
when out on patrol the military police
are in constant communication with MP
headquarters often receive instructions
to be on the lookout for overdue or AWOL
individuals usually these persons are in
town not rung once noted for its
beautiful beaches hotels and temples has
undergone certain changes as local
businessmen vie for the money of Kath
McDermott soldiers colorful Lily's
lounge and the robust Los Angeles bar
are typical examples of the new fun
places to the MPs the gaudy bistros are
frequently the source of trouble and are
under continuous surveillance passing
through the red velvet portal of this
night and a spot the MPS check to make
sure no military personnel are
patronizing the bar during duty hours
the place is empty so the MPS mount up
to continue the patrol incidents of a
serious nature are occurring less and
less as the MP patrols increase
camp Radcliffe home of the first Air
Cavalry Division is located near on K
here on 6 May presentation of division
colors from Major General Harry wo
canard outgoing commander to Major
General John Norton formally launches
the change of command ceremony during
which general Norton will assume
leadership of the air mobile division
general Norton is officially installed
by Lieutenant General Jeannie angler
deputy commanding general US Army
Vietnam and Major General Stanley R
Larson commanding general headquarters
field force 1 as troops to the 1st Air
Cavalry stand in formation the new
commander troops the line 1st cavalry
men salute their new commanding general
as the divisions and the nations flags
fly in the brilliant sunlight general
Norton's most recent assignment was as
deputy commanding general of US Army
Vietnam general canard is assuming
temporary command of field forces 1
while general Larson is on leave after
this temporary duty general canard will
return to the United States for
reassignment as a climax division
helicopters pay tribute to their new
commander and bid farewell to general
canard who helped develop the airmobile
concept and was the first commander to
direct its use in combat
approximately once every two weeks a
freighter completes the journey from New
Orleans to the Dominican Republic where
it unloads enough food and other
supplies to support the 7,000 or more
troops who make up the United States
contingent of the eight thousand plus
inter-american peace force there are 30
dozen eggs in each of these cartons
perishables are unloaded first and
transported in refrigerator vans a prime
necessity in this subtropical climate
all supplies perishable or not are taken
to the fairgrounds Depot complex of the
627 supply and service battalion these
experienced supply experts know that in
this climate food must be placed
immediately in cold storage lockers eggs
like all foods can go bad during
shipment to protect the health of the
troops an army veterinarian is assigned
to inspect each shipment of perishables
that arrive producing daily bakery
products is another function of the
supply and service battalion here
battalion Baker's place dough in a
molder divider assembly to make
two-pound loaves the bread is then baked
for 45 minutes I'm permitted to cool
French rye whole wheat and raisin bread
are among the bakery products the
battalion supplies to their hungry
customers inside this enclosure the
battalion 649 supply and service company
operates a 7000 customer laundry care
and consideration becomes second nature
to men whose official battalion and
company designations contained the word
service the battalions 67th maintenance
support company frequently stops US Army
vehicles on the highway spot checking
them to see if any repairs are needed
minor repairs are made by the unit motor
pool
or major repairs vehicles are sent to
the repair tents of the maintenance
support company each vehicle repaired
and virtually rebuilt will be returned
to its unit in peak operating condition
these jeeps carefully tuned and checked
by the maintenance company will be
donated by aid to the Dominican National
Police they symbolize the wide spectrum
of responsibility which faces US army
supply and service personnel in the
Dominican Republic
general Dae decision FB no chef France
major-general Sir John Nelson of England
and Major General John F Franklin USA
attend the Allied forces Day celebration
in West Berlin on 14 May governing mayor
V Leibrandt and family are next to
arrive
the mayor greets the commanding generals
on behalf of the city colors are born
the length of the parade route the
structure death seats an uni West to
Ernst Reuter plots then along Bismarck
Strasser a combination of three military
bands the pipes and band of the first
battalion the Royal Innes killing
Fusiliers band and the Royal Tank
Regiment camp Raven execute the
traditional British March maneuver left
wheel nine military bands participate in
the overall parade the Jean de Marie
national of France with origins dating
back to the gallo-roman era leads the
mechanized section of the parade with
elements of the Jean de Marie mobile in
the second portion of the parade a
squadron of the Queen's Own hasar as
marches the route various motorized
units participate the original division
uniform is worn by the six US Army
infantry division color guard the state
flags of the 50 states of the USA are
carried by men of the Berlin brigades
special troops an m60 US tank from the
40th armored salutes as it passes the
reviewing stand large crowds attend the
biggest allied event of the year which
demonstrates the unity and might of the
Allied partners for peace in Berlin
the Thailand Armed Forces military
research and development center in
Bangkok is seeking a practical
individual combat ration for their
troops they are working in cooperation
with the u.s. Advanced Research Projects
Agency field unit in Thailand and with
the Thai preserved foods organization
the research and development stages are
completed a limited pilot production
line is now turning out a hundred
individual three meal rations a day when
new machines are received this year the
output will rise to two thousand units
the packages contain dried rice slice
dried fish a Thai soup of cabbage and
vegetables dried beef fish powder and
other dehydrated items dessert is a
sugar peanut candy bar various sealed
packets making up the individual three
meal ration are assembled and placed in
clear plastic bags which are also sealed
the dry food is therefore doubly
protected against tropical humidity
which might otherwise spoil it
throughout the whole process
Quality Control is maintained in this
modern well-equipped laboratory it is
operated by the preserved foods
organization at kiss art University near
Bangkok the laboratory has been working
on the project for the past 18 months
Thai soldier's sample the rations when
hot water is added to 250 grams of rice
in waterproof bags
it becomes 750 grams ready-to-eat in 10
minutes
special tablets placed under the canteen
cups heat the water powdered soup poured
in two cups of hot water is also ready
in a few minutes the rations shown here
by dr. Amara the director of the project
have been field tested by various Royal
Thai Armed Forces and were favorably
received
this is Main Street Fayetteville North
Carolina the 150 year old Fayetteville
Observer is the hometown newspaper for
thousands of members of the 82nd
Airborne Division stationed in the
Dominican Republic they left their
families and their loved ones in the
Fort Bragg Fayetteville area when they
were ordered to Santo Domingo to restore
peace a year ago the Army has made
arrangements for 1,000 copies a day of
the observer to be sent to the soldiers
who call North Carolina a second home
near the large military base at Fort
Bragg is Pope Air Force Base whose
Dominican Republic terminal facilities
are used nightly by a military career
jet to get the newspapers to the readers
in Santo Domingo
within hours the aircraft carrying the
newspapers lands at the headquarters of
the United States forces in the
Dominican Republic from the tail section
of the c-130 the newspapers are
offloaded the papers with all the news
of the activities and interests of the
families back home are dropped at the
various distribution points in the Camp
Randall and Santo Domingo area the
observer is distributed on a basis of
one copy for every seven men and reaches
soldiers everywhere ranging from the
headquarters section of the ia pf2 82nd
division headquarters and units out on
special duty within 24 hours the
observer is in the hands of its readers
in the dominican republic the morale
factor is a large one in a foreign
country where the soldier is away from
the ones he loves and where the
inhabitants speak an unfamiliar language
the Fayetteville Observer is like a
daily letter from home
the first anniversary of the formation
of the inter-american peace force is
held on 6 May to celebrate this sports
events are scheduled between the five
Latin members and the USIA PF forces in
the Dominican Republic in soccer
Paraguay launched the yanks 11 to
nothing in the more familiar game of
basketball the u.s. defeats a Brazilian
Nicaraguan team 83 to 27 the game at the
Brazilian battalion camp is watched by
the AI ApS commanding officer Brazilian
general Alvaro bracha and his deputy
Brigadier General Robert R Linville US
Army the baseball game also goes to the
North Americans as Nicaragua is shut out
by the lopsided score of 21 to nothing
on another field
the Brazilians revenged themselves
against the US forces in volleyball
whipping the Yanks in two sets 15 5 and
15 - but here it's a long home run good
in any park for more US team runs the
following day trophies donated by the
Brazilian government are presented by
General Braga to the team winners at the
IAAF headquarters the awards will
provide memories of a welcome change
from the routine policing and
peacekeeping duties of the
inter-american peace force
in 3 esta italy on 8 May at the
officer's club of the vittorio emanuele
Kaserne competitors are welcomed by
general nani of italy to the boxing
matches of the council international de
sports militare sysm lieutenant colonel
joseph haines US Air Force chief of the
US delegation is seen with
representatives of other countries on
the following day delegates draw lots to
determine their position in the
competition
the lightweight drawing is followed by
another drawing for featherweight
the preliminaries begin on 10 May
flyweight marbly US Army defeats yadegar
of Turkey all US boxers were white with
blue stripes the next bout sees Albert
Johnson US Navy against Jorge of Spain
in the featherweight division to qualify
for entry sysm contestants must be in
active military service the Tres de
palace of sports sees Marine corporal
art Retton decision our chasm of Holland
in the light heavyweight preliminaries
on 14 May the finals are held for the
weight robinson of the navy is seen
again this time matched with song in
north korea in this event robinson wins
by a knockout in the third round
victoria of army boxes to a decision
over hangs off of korea in the
lightweight class
systems international sporting events
seek to improve the sport armies James
Wallington and Sam Pieri of Italy draw
close attention as they clash in the
life welder event for the light
heavyweight finals Marine corporal
redden returns against Barbie era of
Italy and wins on a TKO in the
tournament's final match u.s. navy
heavyweight Richard Pettigrew meets
pekin ally of Italy and wins by a
decision
various dignitaries present medals to
the winners of each division us
contenders take 4 gold and two silver
medals